In Iraq, funerals are being held in Baghdad...
...after security forces opened fire on protesters...
...demonstrating against unemployment, poor public services and corruption.
Thousands of protesters in masks streamed onto Hong Kong's streets...
...after the territory's leader invoked rarely used emergency powers to ban masks at rallies.
In Ecuador, President Lenin Moreno declared a state of emergency,...
...as demonstrators took to the streets across the country...
...to protest the end of a government fuel subsidy.
In Portugal, opinion polls show Prime Minister Antonio Costa's party...
...is set to win the Sunday parliamentary election.
His center-left Socialist Party has ruled the country since 2015.
Finally, from the US,...
...the New York Times is reporting two of President Donald Trump's top envoys to Ukraine...
...drafted a statement in August...
...committing that country to opening an investigation...
...involving Democratic presidential candidate Joe Biden.